hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to fury survivor pixel Z
it's a pixelated style zombie action
top-down smashing Michael Jackson hi
given that I've never played this game
before I have no idea how there's gonna
go what are those I can't shoot those
are I'll grab you then who's okay come
on
well this seems like a nice tempered
game for tempered people mild mannered
me playing this mild mannered game full
of mild mannered zombo's more like
zombozo's out of burgers sorry lady Oh
take that box oh your ghost I can't kill
ghosts for some reason it's against my
ethics oh I've been froze your mistake
was not killing me when you had the
chance
you think you can hit me oh [ __ ] oh that
that okay that's Derek there it was
probably a way to get around those that
I would have understood if I had known
the game I'm going back the ref fouché
as you may have picked up I don't know
how to play this game you see all this
wonderful glorious back at the base
well is it I was gonna say is that Jesus
but that's gabe newell isn't that you
know give no when I see him I know gabe
newell when I see him hello how are you
doing stop reaching for whatever you're
reaching for whatever this is I don't
know what this is and I'm not gonna lie
and be like Oh earned all of this
because I did not earn all of this I'm
gonna be straight up with you so this is
not indicative to the experience I've
got how much is that 1 million coin and
1 5 $50,000 which is wonderful and great
and I have a hundred thousand arrows you
know for huntin so Thank You LT games
for all the goodies in the special
shinies and the good gear and all this
account in high level and Big Damn
big numbers and boom-boom-boom-boom and
thank you for sponsoring this video but
I am gonna do the honorable thing cuz I
am an honorable man but that's not the
point
so what I'm gonna do yo ills okay I got
a fresh version of the game so I'm gonna
go into this eyes blind eyes closed
I'm not even to use any of my six senses
to be able to play this game so this is
the beginning of what happened good
question is everybody gone what happened
to the factory hmm I need to get home
Anna's probably waiting for me probably
what the damn it
who messed up my car better go check it
out this stick looks useful best take it
with me it's not a stick it's it's bad
it's a bad don't you know about when you
see one okay hey Bob Bob Bob run oh geez
I'm not as one piece before there we go
no that's some satisfying warpage oh
yeah oh yeah
Bobby I'm so sorry I'm not so sorry what
the hell happened here okay
[Music]
my god my god
[ __ ] I surrender
oh [ __ ] what result break in just a few
days most of humanity and infected
countless bodies
and all they have now is hope I used to
train in the Marine Corps but I'm just a
simple factory worker now I'm on the
my wife and daughter the wife
not okay used to be used to train in the
Marine Corps you were in a Marine you
just went to the gym with other Marines
like what did you do I can be with them
again soon I need to find my wife all
right I gotta find my wife did you hide
my wife all right there we go got those
is much better see this is what I like
about starting games fresh because this
this really does seem like a game that
I'm gonna love and I don't want to go
into it being like I earned all of these
goodies that I don't know how to use I
wait these don't explode do they let's
find out well I mean they exploded but
they didn't hurt me
oh I guess a Skellington shouldn't be
you're gonna explode each where's my
wife my wife so things explode but
apparently they don't hurt me
which is good cuz I hurt myself give me
my wife you're my no dog you know no
doggy dough for doggies no no no no no
okay thank you thank you dog it's my
wife I'm in this truck
I'll save you I'll save you wife Oh code
oh it does hurt me well [ __ ] man I feel
what I feel bad whomp in the Zombo
humans but the zombie puppies now that's
that's where I draw the line
okay Hibou perk one person level 5 level
mi look at me I'm a handsome man with an
electrical part that I got from that box
I'm sure it still works
no I'm just I leveled up I leveled up
good
see now I get the reward of leveling up
and this got like some good feel to it
like honestly I love I love a good one
and this this games got good one [ __ ]
yeah very very warm feet
that hmm like there's something very
satisfying about her so many corpses
it's a it's a swimming pool and it just
got too crowded
it got so crowded that everybody died oh
good we're good here than I imagined the
factories become some kind of new way
yeah yeah oh yeah just the factory's
become the new HL yeah definitely just
the factories not everything else look
look at the tree Oh God Trio is that you
oh no save you okay all right so that
doesn't hurt me it was a lie
definitely didn't hurt me oh um should i
duck dodge dip Oh okay not the nut uh
okay it's a pattern I think it's gotta
be a pattern right I mean I I could
dodge this with a little less narrowness
why do I need to go here I don't need to
go here I need to go here I should run
into the place where all the cars are
coming from that seems like the obvious
maybe I'll progress safe good good for
me whomping incoming hey you want to pee
yeah you can't even get close to me you
can't even approach but you can't even
touch me I'm 2 1 P for you oh yeah I
wonder what I'm gonna get a gun kind of
would appreciate a gun and some junker I
love little details like this I love
little details like this those are good
like knocking down those signs it has no
gameplay value but it happens when you
run into him and it makes a satisfying
thunk that's good design it doesn't seem
like it on its surface but it's [ __ ]
like that that I appreciate whip the
whip
I thought I worked in a factory what is
this
what kind of alien technology oh hi all
right just gonna be on my way the word
floating oh hi protagonist hey man it's
me the protagonist well your kids call
your solder it's me I gotta find my wife
I'm still kicking I always find someone
anyways why is the protagonist Batman I
always find someone in the end let's get
out of here no don't bother they chewed
on me like a Rudy's on roadkill damn
monsters where in the hell are they
human wins now they're walking Saxon
foolish I'll be one of those rune
victors go ahead use it on me then read
oh oh I can't do something like that
I can't do something like that I'm
Batman I don't kill come with me
shoot me boy Jimmy sweet sweet boy
I can't digging any longer sorry I
shouldn't be laughing at that that's
supposed to be an emotional moment which
is the sudden is of God you like no I
can't do that come on you can do it
please it's all right jiae's stop
badgering me about you know to kill me
I'll scream at you so you don't come
back sorry there's a very serious moment
that I need to take very seriously he's
very emotional okay goodbye whatever
that was oh we're going a different way
now thunk whoop want some Bangi
otters oh I can walk backwards hey you
won't be me I learned
for Michael Jackson I can move up and
shoot at the same time not as satisfying
as the one pitch I'll give that I'm
gonna go back to 1p cuz I like whomp
town one town USA is a good place to
hide lady oh if I time it right I can
get my hidden I love that that's good
[Music]
you know some game designer war all
right time it will enrage give me my why
you get already bats I'm gonna whomp you
I don't care if you're runnin away
alright maybe I'll shoot you that might
be good maybe I should be a bit more
skillful about this but my rage my blind
rage to find my wife I wish there was a
quick swap weapon down lower okay yeah
what if you can chain it up oh no it's
just a sequence so you get oh okay that
happens on every third swing that's nice
though it's the simple things that make
games fun to play the very basic
mechanics need to be absolutely solid
like the the combat the hitting of
zombies cuz what this game 90% of what
people do besides like the crafting and
the base building and you know the fun
my wife is hitting zombies so you got to
make sure that I itself is real fun and
that's what this game does boom what the
never seen a creature like that before I
don't see a creature at all that crappy
spat out really burned my skin you're
talking about the bats oh I'm supposed
to go this way I wasn't supposed to
explore for bonuses bad oh cool
damn dude a candy bar water oh god I'm
gonna need more yeah man
kind of wish I had all those amazing
perks and supplies ye don't bump with my
wife
Chad these goddamn Chad zombies here
Manson bastards didn't steal my wife for
me did you know now you mommy get Cola
I guess colas good for quenching forced
wow you suck why do you suck okay let's
shoot you
you know what no I'm not gonna shoot you
stop tougher than you I'm angry right
burn yeah I missed how did I miss from
point-blank you've got them chance ah me
boy you'd think I'd get infected from
this but no I'm gonna get you not heal
yeah you can't stop me when I got mad
packs
oh yeah give me that that felt good my
wife will be better that one once I find
her hello Oh God Popeye what are you
doing here get out of here sailor
zombies they're either sailors or mimes
or French I don't know which is worse
I'm sorry
well unfortunately I died was one of
those actually an exploding alright
there we go got it yeah you want some of
this yeah you don't want some of this
yeah okay I'm guessing one of those
barrels must have exploded because I
took some do vilage their thumb these
bugs I'm not gonna stop hitting boxes I
don't care if you're in them every
little helps yeah that's right yeah
break 50 objects don't get out of your
score PO oh you're cute actually no a
nevermind I'm sorry for trying to kill
you you're cute you're real cute I must
be taking more damage than I think
because suddenly I look and my health
will be real low I wish there was like
an alert for one my health over there
probably is and I'm probably about a
second yeah Wow
oh you guys weren't so bad what the hell
holy crap wait a minute but I've got a
lot of health wait what I've got 460
what I'm only level 3 did I get it more
items or something
what like a boots looks of health cool
like a pants tattered pants oh that's
what it does that gave me a big boost
health oh okay I don't know where I
found pants cuz I don't remember seeing
fans but apparently I got pants so
that's cool
time to spare kick oh hey listen
I'm in a hurry I'll find my wife she
could be in any one of these boxes or
barrels don't know why he's turning into
Santa hair tattered clothes that seems
like it would be marginally better yes
it is marginally better and very
marginally but it's an upgrade huh oh no
wait what why would that would that be a
thing
wait don't what huh oh oh no does not
good oh I was Wiley coyote there for a
second
all right smelter broken well how does
that affect me oh that's how it affected
me okay all right so look out for the
shadows I see you kabuki cool good I can
fall off I guess I should have taken
them from the whole LA wily coyote
situation but yeah apparently I can fall
off so let's try not to invisible walls
would help me cuz you know it was the
walls they're always on video games so
I'm gonna be smooth about this real
smooth oh there's tank and these on the
top of my dome on the factory worker oh
I probably shouldn't be tanking these
like I am okay any day now good all
right can I get off here no that's not
where I can get off really that looks
suspiciously Allah okay never mind you
know carry on whatever all these weird
hanging zombies okay now I got invisible
walls again I think I'm not gonna test
it yeah it's like it's like been a net
all over again
why are you always having errors what
waveone what woody what what oh hi
Point Blank ow I should have reloaded
before that but you know whatever air
rate we've to but that was way of one
well you can't call it a wave if it's
just one thing no wave or I'm gonna make
a warm anus I don't need pistol I
thought I was gonna have to shoot from
like a distance but turns out no
suspiciously suspecting lean oh yeah
they're getting tougher it's almost like
they went easy on me in the very
beginning of this game okay I'm ridged
oh wait does the range just like explode
and rage is that all it does I think all
it does is just do an area weak kaboom
II come here oh yeah that's what I
thought you suck I'm so angry
oh god help oh god help Tom mid-swing
just slap a few band-aids on me now wave
eight come on come on come on well you
got nothing
oh these bats can't run away if they're
trapped up here oh yeah
quick as can be go quick the flash here
comes the ash god I'm so lame oh you
yeah you want some of this boy rigid you
know stuff I hereby declare I must beat
all bosses with melee there is no other
proper way to do it cuz if I do it any
other way I'm a counter coward I'm a
coward
oh is that an 8k why didn't that zombie
use this against me I'll never know I
guess I have to break my oath as bad man
alright you know this is this is like
hitting with a bat but from a distance I
like it it's good feels right come on
football mama oh yeah I guess hold it
down alright yeah this is good this is
the good stuff yes what I'm talking
about oh well this definitely helps me
not taking is about damage which I think
I probably should start avoiding you
know maybe maybe suspiciously they
really want me to fall I bet there's no
invisible walls there you're not gonna
trick me no way no how
I shoot barrel
to get more feral shooting bullets nice
I love this I love this you I got a gift
hmm
what Oh game at random okay what do I
get
yes the purple one I'm guessing that's
bestest cool what claim what do I get it
on 20 minutes oh that's cool that's cool
though hey hell yeah oh hell yeah oh
hell yeah I'm going back to the pistol
then dehydrated blood loss oh [ __ ] Oh
drink plane these bars beans soup my
wife used to make me soup in beans my
wife
every time I shout my wife at a distance
an angel gets its wings
ah it's one pin Jam I'm so angry one of
the some of these must actually explode
and damage me I think okay upgrade
exactly the same exactly the same not
worth it can i salvaged here we go
salvaged individually salvaged
individually Hey cool all right cool
good I don't know how the crafting
system works but I know that there is a
crafting system oh god back on the
platform's oh hey hi hello thanks main
entrance is just up ahead
I don't feel very safe on this but I
guess everything's okay I'm not
questioning it that much which I'm not
ignorance is bliss thank you for the
trip let me use my new pistol actually
oh yeah it's good stuff there oh yeah I
can just hold it down Wyatt why have I
not been holding it down oh no cuz I'm
an idiot
oh yeah oh yeah you can't stop the pain
now we're tired you know I guess I
should use the wumpy as a last resort
and my last resort I mean exclusively
against bosses oh yeah Oh get uh-huh get
it all oh man that's awesome and there's
so many items
oh is that a boss that's a boss pup Oh
cut it feels bad but here I go yeah
whatever you're doing oh you oh you suck
oh my god you suck I don't care I'm
gonna finish you with this I don't care
how long it takes this is how I do I'm
an honorable zombie dog murderer yeah I
can hold this down too I can hold any of
them down why why do I keep slapping it
I don't know I'm sorry
[Music]
body armor ooh body armor okay all right
okay all right
my health is very low yeah cleave damage
not this way
oh here okay more floaty platforms
thanks way thank you you're very helpful
I don't like the way the eyes on this
building thing bleed like that it's got
a mouth and aizen's very bloody and I
get what they're insinuating but I don't
I don't like it and I like it okay cool
Oh
uh why what what the hell what they have
an arena or something
protect humanity oh wait yeah because
it's got a zombie in it it's not a BOTS
gonna stop it's very clearly not a robot
mm-hmm okay you know what
I'm honorable here I here I go I got you
you're gonna get it now I'm gonna get
you yeah you can't even win is it none
oh okay that hurts yeah that hurts okay
that that hurts that definitely does the
hurt
oof Oh God you know I'm not that
honorable anymore I changed my mind I
changed my mind about honor and dignity
and all that I'm just gonna shoot you
until you've been Shue stood you guys
Schuester there you go that's what I'm
talking about oh yeah get some of that
Oh get some of that oh yeah all of that
actually you can get the majority of
that please oh I do get a damage boost
from that okay that's nice and quick
cool down still it's always late that's
That's Life that's life that's lovely
what I meant to say why do you have a
shield I don't like your shield use
melee weapon oh hell yeah I came for
this day
uh yeah get down yeah yeah I'll take
your rock it's whatever man you think
you can beat me with rockets but no I'll
take this electricity you think you can
beat me with electricity no stupid what
is that what is happening Wow alright
you know what I'm gonna go pistol you
for you oh I can shoot those things I
see I see I see eyes now ow ow ow I'm
gonna go for this okay now I'm being
kind of strategic about it I imagine I
can't just like be slap-happy about the
majority of the boss fights here
I'm just being slap out of here because
this is definitely like a boss fight but
it's still the first boss fight Oh
oh hell yeah and then I got
yeah yeah I got a baby what is this
standard weapon tool make a weapon or
tool Oh for crafting mmm
me likey all right cool but I did that
and I guess that was all just the
chatter look at this thing
give me something to whap oh you better
give me some of the web oh come on they
gotta give me something to wipe they
give me this thing and they don't get me
something to lap right away what I like
most about is that it's an actual game
it's not just like base building
resource management I mean it's got
resources and Scott Base building but at
the same time link and is this laughable
map ooh that my daughter my life wife
excuse me sir 20 I had to deal with that
it was bothering me finally a survivor
on the protagonists for you I'm the
factory's boss bodyguard my guest
currently looking for him do you work
here have you seen him it's a big-ass
factory factories lost taken over by
those monsters I didn't think anybody
made it you'd best come with me I can't
I have my duties I got the boss's
daughter out of here now I got to find
the man himself well alright then take
care
you look worn out you can search the
disparity bus for some food thank you
now I need to get back home
until next time disparity bus I don't
know what disparity bus means but I'll
take it
Artie stew huh wait I got epic food
really mmm that's good I'll save that
for later what I'm feeling really hungry
whoa those land mines alright cool
good bye out take all your stuff looks
like there's a diary here yep I picked
that up on the way give it a read pretty
upsetting you can take it yes sir okay
let's see what happened two minutes late
for work
dock my pay boss yelled at me all
because of that damn hobo if I hadn't
jumped me I wouldn't have missed the
morning bus I can't believe he actually
bit me too come to think of it he looked
pretty bad even for a hobo heavily
bloodshot eyes a fiercely dead stare I
think it was bleeding the more I think
about it the more gives me the creeps
oh but didn't catch anything although
that's been a lousy day out of work a
dull throbbing pain scrubbed it with
antiseptic and alcohol it's like none of
it made a difference the ill go to the
hospital tomorrow
losing pus great all right little eggs
wriggling around
stay sucked my bite her
I had heard my Summit heard in this
thing of fear so screw work I stayed
home last piece of steak and ate it up
tastes strange like it was missing
something even stranger I ate the whole
thing in one go and still then hungry
dropped a piece of Robbie's from floor
before I knew it it was in my mouth it
was delicious what's going on mmm raw
meat mmm yum yum yum the edges are
starting to rot more white bubbles bored
looked at him with a magnifying glass
they have a black tadpole-like thing
inside a whole arm gangrene it's not
more bubbles each time I look the
tadpoles keep I don't feel weak like the
normal fever just like a powerful force
is tearing me apart bursting at the
seams Oh a lab rat jumped in bit a hobo
one became ten can become a hundred now
nobody knows how widespread it is more
armed patrols I can barely recognize
myself I've become that hobo bloodshot
eyes firstly dead stare and looking for
prey yeah I need to go out looking for
prey I'm just so hungry
yep I don't think he turned into a
zombie that's something else definitely
definitely not zombie death and there's
supportable landmines over here I should
take some for later
buy some did you mean all of them I have
unlimited I just stuffed every lip I am
a walking bomb oh boy okay cool my life
oh this games fun chapter two the road
home oh boy
all right I'm just gonna whomp a few
more things with my new thing and then I
think I'm gonna wrap it up because this
is really cool but I think you guys got
a pretty good idea of the game now give
me a like one enemy to whomp that's what
I want okay search looks like all the
cars have been destroyed weird huh door
I'm looking at you but I'm hitting this
car I mean for now it'll be soon be not
over but looks like all the cars are
destroyed weird huh like some maniac
went on a rampage but it was obviously
the zombies damn it for some reason none
of the
cars are working who knows why not
surely not me okay sorry I'm having too
much fun yes looks good doing doing yeah
hey how you doing landmine would you
like a landmine dude he's dead
wow this thing is so powerful bugs dead
car dead truck dead dad this thing is
the best I love this thing this car
looks cool how convenient it's got
spikes in the front oh hell yeah I have
to save my wife a moment of peace my
head is still ringing I remember some
big crate falling then just black while
I was passed out the world turned upside
down
there's only mayhem and murder now but
that's got nothing to do with me at
least not until I find my family I hope
they're safe I think it's got something
to do with you oh please yes Lord
forgive me I have to suppose remorse
with the diffence yes yeah
yeah maybe there's peace for them in
death I think they were already dead
oh hi okay hello I can't stop now wait
this is just a an intro for Road of the
Dead oh oh I'm okay you'll never get me
I'm Duke quick you shouldn't have those
darkening lasers loser Oh what are you
get I was wrong there we go yeah I'm
just gonna ride a line here yeah you
ain't gonna give me you ain't gonna give
me you ain't gonna give me you gonna run
out of bombs you ain't like me with
unlimited land oh my you miss me miss me
I bet you wanna kill don't kiss me miss
me Oh riding the line oh yeah yeah you
miss me miss me
you can't even hug me miss me
oh thank you for that what I'm sorry oh
he blew up from that damn chopper I got
away you mean they died this deadly
virus oh come on protagonist
you just killed hundreds of zombies
hundreds you kill the hundreds put two
and two together smarty
alright the roads blocked why produce
explosives to blow it apart craft
explosives I don't have that I need
sulfur and gas all right I'll find
sulfur and gas actually sadly I think
they're yeah they jumped on me poisoned
impose and nothing stands a chance
against me now that I got this thing
alright so anyway that is sorry I'm just
I just have to search for everything you
guys understand you understand dude so
that is fury survivor pixel Z it is a
really fun game not lying not over
hyping it in any way not exaggerating
you saw it
it's fun it's free it's available for
download right there in the
description if you have iOS or Android
links right down there below click it
you'll get it you'll play it it's super
fun and you can see why I wanted to show
you the beginning of the game as opposed
to having all those special power-ups I
mean the big numbers are cool but
they're meaningless if you don't have
the context of where they come from the
fun about games like this is the
progression of it and it seems like
there's tons of progression to this
because I'm level 5 right now that
character at the beginning was level 55
and all those different things that come
with it is that raw meat so this is fun
so thank you everybody so much for
watching remember you can get this game
down in the description below and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]